Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net Programming Throwdown, Episode 36, Swift. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. So, yeah, last week I was involved in this hackathon which is for people who don't know it's basically you know you have some kind of a theme
本期节目由 Host Tornado 提供托管支持。他们提供网站托管套餐、独立服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net 编程掷标器，第 36 期，Swift。请开始，Jason。大家好。上周我参加了一个黑客马拉松，对于不了解的人来说，这基本上就是你有一个主题
and your goal is to rather quickly come up with some prototype which you know which demonstrates some cool you know some project that project that you've been working on. So, for example, there might be a hackathon on, say, HTML5, and you make some cool way to show videos in your website that's never been done before or something like that. It's pretty cool. It's a lot of fun. I've done a lot of these different hackathons and these 24-hour code challenges
你的目标是尽快拿出一个原型，用来展示一些你一直在做的酷炫项目。例如，可能会有一个关于 HTML5 的黑客马拉松，你在网站里制作了一种展示视频的新颖炫酷方式，这是以前从未有过的，诸如此类。这挺酷的，也很有趣。我参加过很多不同的黑客马拉松以及 24 小时编程挑战赛
and design challenges and things like that. And Patrick, you've done a lot of rapid prototyping with Arduino and along those lines. And it's a lot of fun. Everyone who's, if you're from a hobbyist to a professional, you should definitely give it a shot. There's a ton of them on the internet um like if you're into games there's the ludum dare challenge um there's there's a ton i'm sure whatever whatever topic you're interested in
和设计挑战赛之类的事情。Patrick，你用 Arduino 做过很多快速原型设计，也差不多是这类的。这真的很有趣。无论你是业余爱好者还是专业人士，都绝对应该尝试一下。互联网上有大量的这类活动，如果你喜欢游戏，有 Ludum dare 挑战赛，还有很多很多，我确信无论你对什么话题感兴趣
has some kind of you know hacking contest and it's cool it's a chance for you to sort of showcase something to the rest of the the world or at least to a community of like-minded people and get feedback and things like that. So you would recommend hacking at hackathons? Definitely hack at hackathons. Yeah, definitely. I think sleeping at hackathons, I wouldn't recommend that. That typically doesn't happen. That was what I would do. Yeah, for people who don't know, Patrick has to get his 8 hours otherwise he turns into a hungry Patrick I don't know what you're talking about
都会有某种黑客竞赛。这很酷，这是你向全世界或至少向一个志同道合的社区展示某些成果、获得反馈等的机会。所以你会推荐在黑客马拉松上进行黑客编程吗？绝对推荐在黑客马拉松上编程。是的，绝对推荐。我觉得在黑客马拉松期间睡觉，我不太推荐。通常不会发生这种事。那会是我做的事。是的，对于不知道的人来说，Patrick 必须保证睡满 8 小时，否则他就会变成一个饥饿的 Patrick。我不知道你在说什么
you get 9 hours of sleep I'm a terrible person dude I need my beauty rest in general a couple of tips for these hackathons number one go with a plan and focus on the plan like start with the ui it's it's a complete opposite of an actual project
你睡了 9 小时。我真是个糟糕的人，伙计，我需要我的美容觉。总的来说，关于这些黑客马拉松有几个小建议：第一，带着计划去，并专注于计划——从用户界面（UI）开始，这与实际项目的做法完全相反
like you want to think about it this way like think about at any moment the the hackathon could be over you know even though that's not true, like, they're usually 24 hours or something, but just treat every hour like it's your last hour. And in the sense that, like, don't spend every hour killing yourself as if it's a deadline or anything. But, you know, after one hour, you should have something, like,
你可以这样想：时刻设想黑客马拉松随时可能结束（尽管事实并非如此，它们通常持续 24 小时左右），但要把每一个小时都当成是最后一个小时来对待。这并不是说让你像面对死线那样拼命去榨干每一个小时，而是说，比如过了一个小时之后，你应该已经有一些东西
that you can at least look at, even if it's just an empty screen. Like, after two hours, you should have something. that you can at least look at even if it's just an empty screen like after two hours you should have something and and kind of work backwards and you'll notice you'll find that like a lot of your ideas that get thrown out are really ones that didn't matter like for example in this hackathon i wanted a settings page where people could sort of customize their experience but you know I started backwards from the experience and I never got to the settings page. And if I had done that in the opposite order,
至少可以拿出来看看，哪怕它只是一个空屏幕。比如，过了两个小时后，你应该已经有些成果了，至少可以拿出来看看，哪怕它只是一个空屏幕。比如说过了两个小时后你应该已经有些成果了，然后倒推着来做。你会发现，很多被你抛弃的想法其实都是些无关紧要的东西。例如，在这个黑客马拉松中，我原本想要一个设置页面，让人们可以自定义他们的体验，但我从用户体验倒推回来，结果根本没时间做设置页面。如果我按相反的顺序做
I'd have nothing to demonstrate. I'd be like, hey guys, here's my project. It's a settings page. You know, I would have like, would have totally bombed. So, you know, it's really good. Rapid prototyping in general is a really good skill. And I say skill because it's not something you can learn. You have to just cultivate it.
我将一无所有，无法展示。我会说：“嘿，各位，这是我的项目，它是一个设置页面。”你知道的，那样我就会彻底搞砸。所以，快速原型设计总体来说是一项非常棒的技能。我之所以说它是技能，是因为它不是靠死记硬背能学会的，你必须去培养它。
And I highly recommend it. Yeah, I think that's good advice to do it the opposite way you would normally do it. But I know a lot of people, well, I guess you should somewhat, that mindset is applicable to everyday life or everyday work. But I agree. I saw a lot of people whenever you do these kinds of things or like even in school, when people work on projects, they would end up with some sort of what they would call like tech demo at the end. They would worked a lot on some piece of infrastructure. And then in the end, they ended up with kind of nothing because they didn't, you know, it was just like some sort of
我极力推荐它。是的，我觉得反常规操作是一个很好的建议。但我认识很多人，或者说我觉得某种程度上，这种心态也适用于日常生活或日常工作。不过我同意。我看到很多人在做这类事情时，甚至在学校里做项目时，到最后往往只会搞出一个他们称之为“技术演示”的东西。他们在某些基础设施上花了很多功夫，结果到头来两手空空，因为他们没有——你知道的，那只是一些
processing in the background and no kind of good visualization way. If you start kind of nothing because they didn't, you know, it was just like, uh, some sort of processing in the background and no kind of good visualization way. If you start kind of like faking the data and make it look nice, uh, and then kind of work back to actually make the processing, it's easier for people to imagine or believe that you can do the hard part, um, in this scenario. So for a prototyping, that's really useful. Like, is it worth investing in actually getting the algorithm to work right now in real life, you may actually that is the key point, right? And so you don't care about the other stuff. But for demos, it's much easier if you can say, here's what it will look like when the when the algorithm works.
后台处理过程，却没有好的可视化呈现方式。如果你一开始就伪装数据让它看起来很棒，然后倒推回去实际实现这个处理过程，那么在这种情况下，人们更容易想象或相信你能搞定那部分难点。所以对于原型制作来说，这非常有用。比如，现在花精力把算法在现实中真正跑通是否值得？在实际生活中，这或许才是关键点，所以你不在乎其他方面。但对于演示而言，如果你能说“当算法运作时，它就会是这个样子”，那就容易得多了。
Exactly. It's exactly right. You have to sort of like, as I said before, you have to like plan beforehand. And that part you can do like kind of of like, as I said before, you have to plan beforehand. And that part you can do kind of bottom up. Like when I had planned it before the hackathon started, I'd kind of started with the settings page and kind of drew little diagrams of sort of how I wanted it to look. But then when I actually got to coding, you know, when they started the clock or whatever, then it was all about the UI. So yeah, a lot of fun.
完全正确。就是这样。你必须像我之前说的那样，事先做好规划。那部分你可以采用自下而上的方式。比如在黑客马拉松开始前做好规划时，我差不多是从设置页面开始的，还画了些小图表来规划我希望它呈现的样子。但当我真正开始写代码时，也就是计时开始后，重点就全在 UI 上了。所以，真的非常有趣。
You guys should definitely try it. So this week we have a question from Mike and I'll summarize. He wrote a little bit more, but that basically he's still in school and that he gets, every time he asked for career advice, people say to get involved in open source projects or communities. And he was asking if we had any recommendations for that specifically i actually don't have a great recommendation for an open source project to join i too also got this advice
你们绝对应该尝试一下。本周我们收到了 Mike 的一个提问，我来总结一下。他写的内容稍微多了一点，但大意是说他还在上学，每次他征求职业建议时，大家都会让他参与开源项目或社区。他想问我们在这方面有没有什么具体建议。其实我对于加入哪个开源项目并没有什么太好的建议，我当年
when i was in school and had the same thing if you ask people well what open source project is good to join or is open for contribution you always get this like you know we'll first start by helping to document the project or looking at the bugs and trying to fix bugs. But there's a lot of work you have to do to get to that point on any kind of mainstream open source project that you would know, I'm not saying you can't do it. And I know people vaguely who, who have done it before. But I think a lot of the open source project opportunities that you should be most interested in first are the smaller projects like maybe it's just one guy who has some interesting tool and you think of a new way that the tool could work because if it's just one guy it's much more likely that you're able to kind of understand the code base and make contributions more quickly which in my opinion
在学校时也听到过这种建议，遇到了同样的情况。如果你问别人：“有什么好的开源项目可以加入，或者接受贡献吗？”你通常会得到这样的回答：“嗯，首先从帮助编写文档开始，或者看看 Bug 列表并试着修复 Bug。”但对于任何你所知的主流开源项目，你要做到那一步需要做大量的工作。我并不是说你做不到，我也隐约认识一些曾经做到过的人。但我认为，你首先最应该感兴趣的开源项目机会，其实是那些较小的项目。也许只是某个家伙做的一个有趣的工具，然后你想到了这个工具的一种新用法。因为如果项目只有一个人，你更有可能看懂代码库并更快地做出贡献。依我之见
when you're first starting out is a better feedback mechanism because you see your work actually leading to something versus just spending like six months trying to figure out where to put your code. Um, you can actually make a contribution or, you know, even creating your own open source project for something that you've been using and you say, Hey, this might be helpful to someone and posting it up and see what other people that you may get harsh criticisms or, you know, shocker, the internet has some people who are jerks and they may say mean things about it but some people will have legitimate like hey you may want to
当你刚开始时，这是一种更好的反馈机制，因为你能看到自己的工作真正起到了作用，而不是花上六个月去琢磨该把代码放在哪里。嗯，你其实可以做出贡献，甚至为你一直在使用某种东西创建自己的开源项目，然后说：“嘿，这对别人可能会有帮助”，把它发布出去，看看其他人的反应。你可能会遭到严厉的批评，或者——惊不惊喜，互联网上总有些混蛋，他们可能会说些难听的话。但也会有人提出合理的建议，比如：“嘿，你可能想
consider this or you have a security problem here or whatever and then that feedback can be really helpful and I think as far as when it comes time for a job you'll have learned some stuff there and you'll have something to point people to and say here's work I did but don't feel like you have to join like open ssl and make contributions or the linux kernel or
考虑一下这个”，或者“你这里有个安全问题”之类的话。然后这些反馈会非常有用。我想当面试找工作的时候，你已经在那里学到了一些东西，并且有一些成果可以指给别人看，说：“这是我做过的工作。”但不要觉得你必须去加入像 OpenSSL 这样的项目并做出贡献，或者 Linux 内核，或者
you know some one of these really big open source projects don't feel like when people say that that's good like those are what they mean there's a whole range of things that you can do yeah definitely i mean i feel like unless you're actually contributing to the Linux kernel, because you it's your job or something like that. Like a lot of those huge code bases are actually a nightmare. And it's nothing against them. It's just, that's just, you know, a lot of these things grow organically. And they don't grow in the, in the, you know, most pristine way. Right. And so, so yeah as patrick said your best bet is choosing something small and starting from there yeah and there may be exceptions to rule but it's the same
诸如此类真正的大型开源项目。不要觉得别人那样说是指那种项目。你可以做的事情其实有很多。是的，绝对是这样。我的意思是，除非你真的在为 Linux 内核做贡献，因为那是你的工作或者其他原因。许多那样的大型代码库实际上就是一场噩梦。这并不是针对它们，只是说，你知道的，很多这类项目都是野蛮生长的，它们的发展方式并不是最完美原始的。没错。所以，正如 Patrick 所说，你最好的选择是挑一个小项目，然后从头开始。是的，凡事都有例外，但这跟
thing like whenever you start a new job or join a team it's kind of weird because they went through a lot of effort to get you or hire you or bring you on but then it's always like it's been my experience that many times when you first join a team nobody kind of has the time to help you everybody's too busy to help you, right? They need your help, but not right now because they don't have time to kind of help you get started. And so, you know, nice people will point you in general direction, but you spend your first few weeks kind of twiddling your thumbs a lot
每当你开始一份新工作或加入一个团队时的情况一样。这有点奇怪，因为他们花了很多精力去争取你、雇佣你或把你招进团队，但根据我的经验，很多时候当你刚加入一个团队时，根本没人有时间帮你，每个人都忙得不可开交，对吧？他们需要你的帮助，但不是现在，因为他们没空帮新手起步。所以，好心人会给你指个大致方向，但你刚进去的前几周，基本上都是在无所事事地转动大拇指
because no one has the time right now to help you with something. And I think that's just kind of one of those facts of life of way things work out that open source projects are probably similar the guys or girls contributing are spending their time doing their contributions and then bringing on new people is probably like a second priority to them and so it's you know like again except maybe in some exceptions they're probably more interested in in spending their time actually doing the work. Right. And so that's what makes it difficult to join if you're not just super, super self-motivated,
因为现在没有人有时间帮你处理任何事情。我觉得这只是生活中的现实之一，开源项目大概也是如此。那些贡献代码的男男女女正忙着做他们自己的贡献，把新人带上路对他们来说可能是第二优先事项。所以，你看——再次说明，除了少数例外情况——他们可能对花时间真正干活更感兴趣。没错。这就导致了加入的难度很大，除非你超级、超级有自我驱动力
which some people are. And, you know, I'm glad there are people like that in the world. Yeah, yeah, definitely. Yeah, that's really good advice. Start something small, preferably something you work on yourself. And, you know, GitHub has kind of reached this critical mass now where, I mean, I don't know about you, but I tend to, like, search specifically in GitHub for projects. Like, the other day I needed a Node.js LDAP library. And I just went straight to GitHub. And I found some guy's library that he wrote in his spare time.
而有些人确实如此。我也很高兴世界上有这样的人。没错，确实如此。这真的是很好的建议。从小事做起，最好是你自己也在用的项目。而且，GitHub 现在已经达到了这样一个临界点：我是说，我不知道你们怎么样，但我倾向于专门在 GitHub 上搜索项目。比如前几天我需要一个 Node.js LDAP 库，我直接去了 GitHub，然后找到了一位老兄在业余时间写的库。
It was just a one-man operation. And he grabbed it. And I found there were some bugs in it. I filed bugs. I made some changes. And so if you put your project on GitHub, write some decent documentation. And if it's something pretty niche or you're doing it better than everyone else,
那完全是由一个人运营的项目。我拿来用了，发现里面有些 Bug，于是我提交了 Bug 报告并做了一些修改。所以，如果你把自己的项目放到 GitHub 上，写点像样的文档，如果它是一个相当小众的领域，或者你比其他人做得更好
you'll generate interest. Definitely. All right, time for news so yeah this is I think this might be the first time on a show we've ever made a mistake I'm pretty sure maybe our first legitimate official
你就会引起关注。绝对的。好了，新闻时间。所以，是的，这可能是我们节目历史上第一次犯错。我很确定，这或许是我们第一次正儿八经的官方
retraction but well no I went and read all I listened to all the old episodes and turns out we never made any mistakes until now it's shocking but yeah so we announced last episode that Twitch was going to be bought by Google
收回前言。不过，等等，我去读了所有……我听了所有往期节目，结果发现我们以前从未犯过错，直到现在。这真让人震惊。所以，我们在上一期节目中宣布 Twitch 将被谷歌收购
we showed what Luddites we are when Twitch got bought by Amazon a few days ago it turns out people were overstating their belief in the rumor that twitch would be bought by google and we like the terrible people we are man i'm saying that too much tonight
这充分说明了我们是多么的老古董。就在几天前，当 Twitch 被亚马逊收购时，结果证明人们对“Twitch 将被谷歌收购”这一谣言的笃信被夸大了。而我们，就像我们这群糟糕透顶的人一样——天哪，我今晚说这词太多了——
like the people we are the uh innocent not believing that the internet could ever have a lie on it we just took it and said oh that must be true and yeah but uh according yeah according to this forbes article um you know they were about to be bought by google but there were some issues um related to antitrust and things like that actually let me let me be more clear there were issues about the potential of antitrust litigation that could happen but didn't actually happen so jc has no idea and he's not a lawyer and it's all yeah it's all still rumor that's right that's right well it's on this Forbes article yeah but yeah you're right it's not it's not validated in any way but
就像我们这样的人，居然天真地不相信互联网上会有谎言，我们直接照单全收，还说“哦，那一定是真的”。不过，根据这篇福布斯文章的说法，你知道的，他们本来确实快被谷歌收购了，但有一些与反垄断法之类相关的问题。其实，让我说得更清楚一点：当时存在引发反垄断诉讼的可能性，但实际上并没有发生。所以 JC 完全不知道他在说什么，他也并非律师，这一切，是的，都还只是谣言。没错，没错。好吧，这篇福布斯文章上是这么写的。但你说得对，它并没有经过任何证实，不过
yeah so Amazon bought them which I think is pretty cool you, I personally have never liked the YouTube kind of user experience. Like, in fact, if you want to see the current live streams on YouTube, you actually have to go to this crazy, like, YouTube slash and then this hexadecimal string. And that's the only way to get a list of the live streams. And so, I mean, i know that youtube's not live streams aren't really their thing but still i just i feel like the ui i just never really been happy with youtube um from experience standpoint and so you know it's kind of like specifically for live streaming that's what you're talking about though right or like in general you just
是的，亚马逊收购了他们，我觉得这挺酷的。我个人其实一直不太喜欢 YouTube 的那种用户体验。实际上，如果你想看 YouTube 上的当前直播，你必须访问一个非常奇葩的网址，比如 youtube.com 斜杠后面跟着一串十六进制字符串。那是获取直播列表的唯一方法。所以，我知道 YouTube 的核心业务其实不是直播，但我还是觉得它的 UI……从体验的角度来看，我一直对 YouTube 不是很满意。所以，你知道的，这有点像是专门针对直播的，这就是你刚才想表达的，对吧？还是说总体上你只是
don't like youtube i like the service i don't feel like the UI, the user experience is there. That's my opinion. Anyway, I can go into a soapbox about that, but I'll spare everyone. And actually, you know, a lot of the internet, a lot of Reddit and things like that have echoed similar statements. Oh, so you read something on Reddit. I see now. I see where this is going yeah i've been blinded by reddit no but i know i should i was it was kind of for me it was a little
我不喜欢YouTube，我不太喜欢它的服务，我感觉它的界面和用户体验不太行。这是我的个人看法。不管怎样，我可以就此大方陈词，但我还是放过大家吧。其实，你知道吗，互联网上很多人，比如Reddit上的很多人，都表达过类似的观点。哦，所以你在Reddit上读到了些东西。我明白了，我懂这是怎么回事了。好吧，我确实被Reddit洗脑了。不，但我知道，其实对我来说，这算是一种
bit of uh um it was kind of a relief to see other people thought the way i did because sometimes i think i'm just i'm just crazy no that's true well yeah that's also true anyway so uh they got bought by amazon um which is pretty cool you know my guess is that Amazon will leave them as is. Amazon tends to do that with a lot of their acquisitions. They don't really try to run their life or anything, which is pretty cool. I think Twitch is pretty great. I've actually been listening to a lot of streams while I've been working. So last time we talked about the Dota 2, the International.
释放，因为看到其他人也和我有一样的想法，我松了一口气，因为有时候我觉得自己是不是疯了。不，这倒也是真的。好吧，反正它们被亚马逊收购了，这挺酷的。我猜亚马逊会维持现状不管它们。亚马逊对很多收购的公司都采取这种态度。他们不会真的去干涉人家的运营，这挺不错的。我觉得Twitch挺棒的。我工作的时候其实经常听一些直播。所以上次我们谈到了Dota 2的国际邀请赛。
What have you been watching on Twitch since that's over now so obviously we're watching there's a guy who you're not gonna believe this there's a guy who is this fish play pokemon i've seen that which is pretty awesome i've also seen goldfish play street fighter oh maybe that's what i'm thinking of there's both um but the one i saw is this guy he's a chef and he just kind of talks about food and stuff and he also does these like speed eating challenges so it has nothing to do with video games so you watch live streams of non-video not really yeah so i thought twitch was like solely about video games well um it could be whatever you want right i mean they can't really i've only ever watched video games on it it It is video game centric. There's no doubt.
自从那个结束之后，你在Twitch上看些什么呢？所以很显然，我们在看一个——你绝对不会相信——有一个家伙，有个人在让鱼玩宝可梦。我见过那个，挺酷的。我还见过金鱼玩《街头霸王》。哦，也许我想到的是那个。这两种都有。但我看到的那个是一个厨师，他就在那儿聊聊食物什么的，他还做那种大胃王挑战。所以这和电子游戏一点关系都没有。那你看的直播不是电子游戏的？也不全是，对。所以我以前以为Twitch全都是关于电子游戏的。嗯，它可以是你想要的任何内容，对吧？我是说，他们其实……我以前只在上面看过电子游戏。它确实是以电子游戏为核心的，这是毫无疑问的。
But there's nothing to stop you from doing whatever you want. Okay. So this guy actually, the last time I saw him, heard him, he ate a pizza, a medium-sized Domino's pizza in a minute, 16 seconds. That's just gross. I know. It's unbelievable. And yeah, you just got to gotta see it if you go on youtube
但没有什么能阻止你去做任何你想做的事。好吧。所以这个家伙，我上次看到他、听到他的时候，他吃了一个披萨，一个中号的多米诺披萨，用了一分钟十六秒。这太恶心了。我知道。这简直难以置信。是的，你只要去YouTube上看看
you can watch a replay i can go on oh this is confusing i have to go on youtube to watch a replay of a twitch tv live stream uh yeah maybe you can watch it on twitch okay i mean does twitch have replay anyways where is this a digress digression. But you should watch it. It's pretty cool. Just put, like, Guy Eats Domino's Pizza in two minutes or something like that. Okay, Guy Eats Domino's Pizza. His name is Caleb Hart. So, here, I'll put it in parentheses in the show notes.
就能看回放。我可以去——哦，这太让人糊涂了，我还得去YouTube上看Twitch TV直播的回放。呃，对，也许你可以在Twitch上看。好吧，我是说Twitch有回放功能吗？总之，扯远了。但你应该去看看，挺酷的。只要搜一下，比如“某人两分钟吃完多米诺披萨”之类的。好吧，“某人吃多米诺披萨”。他叫卡勒伯·哈特（Caleb Hart）。所以，我会把它放在节目文稿的括号里。
Okay. But, yeah, it's pretty epic. It's a very large man, and he eats a pizza very quickly. Okay, interesting. All right, I'll have to check that out later, because I'm going to get distracted if I read that right now. So my next news story is not a news story at all. Well, it's not really news, but it's a blog post that I read,
好的。但是，真的，这太绝了。那是个身材魁梧的家伙，他吃披萨吃得极快。好吧，很有意思。好了，我待会儿得去看看，因为如果我现在就看的话，我会分心的。所以我的下一则新闻根本算不上新闻。好吧，其实不算新闻，而是我读的一篇博客文章，
and we were discussing this at work and sharing our anecdotal stories about it. And the blog, well, you'll have the link in the the show notes um but basically it's called norris numbers that's the title of blog post makes it always sound awesome i wish i thought of cool names to title stuff like this like the norris number so uh this guy is writing about a friend who has a quote about a friend or something who's called norris cliff norris and he says that the norris number is the amount of code an untrained programmer can write before they hit a wall.
我们在上班时讨论过这个，并分享了相关的轶事。那篇博客——嗯，你们会在节目文稿里找到链接——但基本上它叫“诺里斯数字”（Norris Numbers），那是博客文章的标题。这总让人觉得很酷，我希望我也能想出这么酷的名字来给这类东西命名，比如“诺里斯数字”。所以，这家伙写了一个朋友，他有一个关于朋友的名言什么的，那个人叫诺里斯·克利夫·诺里斯（Cliff Norris），他说“诺里斯数字”是一个未经训练的程序员在撞墙之前能写出的代码量。
And so they were talking about like the estimates of it or whatever, like 1500 lines of code, 2000 lines of code. Now there's a whole thing you can get on about flying. The code is a good measure or bad measure or what it measures. But leaving all that aside, I feel like this is a good point that when you or what it measures but leaving all that aside i i feel like this is a good point that when you talk to people who are just fresh out of university or while you're in
所以他们就在讨论关于这个的估算什么的，比如1500行代码，2000行代码。现在这里有很多关于飞行的讨论。代码是一个好的衡量标准，还是坏的衡量标准，或者它究竟衡量了什么。但抛开这些不谈，我觉得这是一个很好的观点，当你和那些刚毕业的大学生交谈时，或者当你还在
university um or school that you write code that's very certain manner and very like architecture seems to be really lacking in most of those projects because it's not what it's about and you'll never write enough code that architecture will kind of really matter because you're not going to maintain it. You only are going to work on it for a few weeks. So you can just kind of spit out code. And you, in some ways, are very efficient because you know you're going to stop.
大学或学校学习时，你写代码的方式是非常固定的，而且大多数项目似乎都非常缺乏架构设计，因为这不是重点，而且你写代码的量永远不会大到让架构真正变得重要，因为你不会去维护它。你只需要在这个项目上工作几个星期。所以你可以直接把代码吐出来。而且在某些方面，你效率很高，因为你知道你要停下来。
But that kind of doesn't work in the workplace. But yet in the workplace, the coding initially kind of comes out the same way. And it takes kind of training and thinking and experience to be able to kind of write something more than these people are claiming about 2,000 lines of code. We'll go with that for now. So once you get above 2,000 lines of code, for instance, you start having problems like if your organization of what code is in what files or what classes and how the data flows. Not a performance problem but a like how do i move around the code and if someone else might be working on it right like how do we
但这种方式在职场中就行不通了。然而在职场中，最初写出来的代码往往还是那种老样子。需要经过培训、思考和经验，才能写出超过这些人所说的2000行代码的东西。我们目前先定这个数字。所以一旦你的代码超过了2000行，比方说，你就会开始遇到一些问题，比如你的代码组织方式、哪些代码放在哪个文件或哪个类里、数据是如何流动的。这不是性能问题，而是关于我如何在代码中穿梭，如果别人也可能在协作的话，比如我们如何
work on two things at the same time so you have to kind of learn those things before you can get to they're saying the next wall which this guy's saying is like 20000 lines of code and when you get to 20,000 lines of code uh that you can still kind of have like a you know loosey-goosey approach if there's multiple people for instance but then if you want to make it to like 200,000 lines of code you need even more very strict organization you need like uh someone really writing the for instance like style guides because you need the code to be consistent uh deciding what goes in and out of the project. So like not adding features just because they might be nice to have, but actually only writing the features you need. And so he's just kind of talking about these like leveling up as a programmer.
同时处理两件事情？所以你必须先学会这些，然后才能达到他们所说的下一堵墙，这家伙说这堵墙大约是20,000行代码。当你写到20,000行代码时，如果有好几个人协作，你可能还能采取那种比较随意的态度。但如果你想把代码量推进到比如200,000行，你就需要更加严格的组织，比如需要有人来真正编写风格指南，因为你需要代码保持一致，还需要决定什么东西该放进项目，什么东西该剔除。所以不是因为功能“听起来不错”就加上去，而是只编写你真正需要的功能。所以他其实就是在讨论程序员的这种“升级打怪”。
And I thought it was an interesting read because I personally I don't read a lot of articles that talk about the craft of programming like that uh and so it was kind of interesting to read and then thinking in my own kind of growth how that like oh yeah initially you write spaghetti code and then you realize like that doesn't work and then you do other stuff and how that like you as you're leveling up the complexity and size of the project how you have to bring new techniques to bear and a lot of times you don't know them initially like you don't know how to write a 200,000 line of the project how you have to bring new techniques to bear and a lot of times you don't know them initially like you don't know how to write a 200 000 line of code project um and then you kind of learn it over time and figure out what works and doesn't work but then you keep hitting these things that prevent you from growing even bigger yeah this is really interesting yeah i think uh it's really interesting because you can kind of see the wall
我觉得这是一篇很有趣的读物，因为我个人不怎么看那种探讨编程工艺的文章，所以读起来挺有意思的。然后我联想到自己成长历程中的变化——哦，对，一开始你写的是面条代码，然后你意识到这样行不通，接着你就会做点别的；随着项目复杂度和规模的提升，你必须运用新的技术，而很多时候你一开始并不懂这些，比如你不知道该如何编写一个200,000行代码的项目。然后你会随着时间慢慢摸索，弄清楚什么行得通，什么行不通，但接着你又会不断遇到阻碍你进一步成长的瓶颈。是的，这真的很有趣。是的，我觉得这很有趣，因为你可以看到那堵墙
coming like for example there's one project i worked on where there was effectively like a like a main control loop file that was you know like 20 000 lines of code in one file and you just know that the wall is like evident you know like you just know that like what they're doing isn't scalable um and uh you know i'm sure you know even if you look at smaller projects you could start to see something where you it's like okay this isn't going to this is going to end badly yeah and in one measure is kind of velocity right like and even this is a little off topic from what this is talking about but i've noticed my own projects that that you, when I work on that work that you go through these cycles and some people call it like technical debt,
正在逼近。例如，我曾参与过这样一个项目，里面有一个主控制循环文件，一个文件竟然有大约20,000行代码，你一眼就能看出这堵墙显而易见，你知道他们这种做法是不可扩展的。而且，我敢肯定，即使你看看较小的项目，你也能开始看出某些端倪，你会觉得，好吧，这可要以悲剧收场了。是的，从某种程度上讲，这也是衡量开发速度的一种标准。虽然这和刚才讨论的话题有点偏离，但我注意到在我自己的项目中，当你致力于某项工作时，你会经历这些周期，有些人称之为技术债，
but like if you can keep throwing more people and work harder and trying to like add more features. But at some point if you're not kind of thinking through like re architecting the system, you eventually get this organic growth problem where you start to lose a lot of velocity and trying to just keep things working right and then you have to kind of do a re-architecting and then you can go really fast again yeah like a very common problem you see is like for example you know there's some class and the class is variable called you know latitude
但如果你一直不断地塞进更多人、更努力地工作、试图添加更多功能，但如果在某个时刻你没有去思考重新架构系统，你最终会遇到这种有机增长带来的问题，你会开始失去很多开发速度，只是为了让系统勉强维持运转。然后你不得不进行重新架构，之后你的开发速度才能再次飞升。是的，一个非常常见的问题是，比如某个类里面有一个变量叫“纬度”，
and then you end up with like another variable called previous latitude and then somebody realizes oh no i need three levels deep so i need like previous previous latitude and then you find out oh i need uh i need an array of latitudes like a history so you create like a array called like latitude history but then you're in a hurry so you don't delete the previous latitude you keep it around and then like you can just see like this and you just know that this is going to end badly or like you're going to need some kind of major refactoring at some point yeah the current problem i work work try to work through is whether or not like when you first start a project how much time do you spend architecting? Because you could spend kind of an infinite amount of time stuck trying to figure out what to do without ever doing anything.
然后你最终又搞出了另一个变量叫“先前纬度”，接着有人意识到，哦不，我需要三层深度，所以我需要“先前的先前纬度”。然后你发现，哦，我需要一个纬度数组来记录历史，于是你创建了一个名为“纬度历史”的数组。但因为你当时很赶时间，你没有删掉原来的“先前纬度”，而是把它留着。然后你可以看到这种情况，你心里很清楚这最后会以悲剧收场，或者你迟早需要进行某种重大的重构。是的，我目前在努力解决的问题是，当你刚开始一个项目时，究竟该花多少时间在架构设计上？因为你可能会花无限的时间卡在琢磨该怎么做上，却什么也没做成。
And so you've got to get started at some point. So you kind of have to pick the lines, even if you know the requirements may change. So you kind of have to do your best and trade off like getting going versus flexibility. Because you could write the most flexible system in the world, but it doesn't do anything. It's just really flexible. It can do anything, but it does nothing. Yeah. You have to make the trade off between being data driven and building a Turing machine. Right. Yeah. I mean like on one end, uh,
所以你必须在某个时刻开始动手。因此你必须划定界限，即使你知道需求可能会发生变化。所以你必须尽力而为，在“开始行动”和“灵活性”之间做出权衡。因为你可以写出世界上最具灵活性的系统，但它什么也不做。它只是极具灵活性，它能做任何事，但实际上什么也没做。是的。你必须在“数据驱动”和“构建图灵机”之间做出权衡。对。是的。我的意思是，一方面，
you want, you know, for example, like CSS, right. If you're, you know, for example, like CSS, right? If you're building a website, you don't want to have all of your style in the HTML. And then every time you want to change, you know, or in the JavaScript, and every time you want to, you know, make a font bigger, you have to go and hack code. But on the flip side, you don't want to create some, like, wild, you know, thing that compiles to something which compiles to css so that you can just like write everything then you've basically just like kind of created your own language that you're gonna have to code in you haven't really gotten anywhere and so somewhere in between there is kind of the sweet spot yep all right cool so yeah my next news is also not
比方说，比如CSS，对吧？如果你在构建一个网站，你肯定不希望把所有的样式都写在HTML里，然后每次你想改动的时候（或者写在JavaScript里），每次你想把字体改大一点，都得去苦哈哈地改代码。但另一方面，你也不想搞出某种疯狂的、能编译成其他东西再编译成CSS的奇葩玩意儿，好让你能随心所欲地写代码。那样的话，你基本上就等于自己发明了一门还得去编写代码的新语言，根本没有解决任何问题。所以，这两者之间的某个平衡点才是绝佳的选择。好，太棒了！那么，我的下一则新闻也不是
really a news but it's it's uh it a really, really good read for people who are interested in this kind of sampling methods. It's called Gibbs Sampling for the Uninitiated. And as the name suggests, or as the name actually just outright says, you don't have to be initiated on Bayesian methods or sampling methods to understand what's going on in this paper. But just to give you kind of like a little preamble. So you know this, have you seen this where if you have, say, like a circle inscribed in a square and you randomly throw darts at the square, you can estimate. So, okay, one thing is, let's say you have some circle inscribed in a square and you want to know the area of that circle or you want to know a random point on that circle. Let's start there. So, one way to do it is to just, you know, throw darts at the circle randomly, or throw darts at
真正的新闻，但对于对这类抽样方法感兴趣的人来说，这是一篇非常非常棒的读物。它叫做《写给门外汉的吉布斯抽样》（Gibbs Sampling for the Uninitiated）。正如它的名字所暗示的，或者说正如它的名字直接表达的那样，你不需要精通贝叶斯方法或抽样方法，就能看懂这篇论文里讲的内容。不过，为了先做一点简单的铺垫。你知道这个吗，你见过这种情况吗：假设你在一个正方形里内切一个圆，然后向正方形随机掷飞镖，你就可以估算出……好吧，假设你在正方形里内切了一个圆，你想知道这个圆的面积，或者你想找出圆上的一个随机点，我们从这里开始。所以，其中一种方法就是，你知道的，随机向圆掷飞镖，或者向正方形掷飞镖，
the square, because you can easily do that. You just pick a random X within the range of the square and pick a random Y, and you throw a dart there. If the dart hits the circle, then you use that point. You say, here's my random point on the circle. If the dart misses and hits the little corners around the circle, on the outside of the circle, then you throw another dart,
因为这很容易做到。你只需在正方形的范围内随机挑选一个X坐标，再随机挑选一个Y坐标，然后把飞镖掷出去。如果飞镖击中了圆，那么你就采用这个点。你会说，这就是我在圆上找到的随机点。如果飞镖没击中，而是击中了圆周围的小角落、也就是圆的外面，那么你就再掷一次飞镖，
and you don't count that dart. And so it turns out, this is called rejection sampling. And so it turns out this is fine. Like doing these darts and throwing some of the darts away is the same as like from a math standpoint as like picking a random spot from the circle. But it's a lot easier to do because, you know,
而且不把那个飞镖算进去。结果证明，这被称为拒绝抽样（rejection sampling）。结果证明这没问题。从数学的角度来看，进行这些掷飞镖并丢弃一部分飞镖的操作，就等同于从圆中随机挑选一个点。但这样做要容易得多，因为，你知道的，
it's easier to pick a random spot in a square and then throw some of them out than it is to like figure out the equation for all the random spots that could be in a circle right okay so this is sort of like an easy way to do a hard thing right and so you can actually you start to know what's in the circle versus not that's right because it's easier to know whether you're in the circle or not then it is to like know the distribution of points in a circle like that second one is hard right um so the uh so and you can do this to approximate pi right you can like you know that if you throw
在正方形里随机挑个点并扔掉一部分，要比找出圆内所有可能随机点的方程容易得多，对吧？好了，所以这有点像用简单的方法做一件困难的事情，对吧？这样你实际上就可以开始区分什么是圆内的点，什么是圆外的点，对吧？因为弄清楚你是否在圆内，要比弄清楚圆内点的分布容易得多，后一种情况很难，对吧？所以，你可以用这个方法来近似计算圆周率π，对吧？你可以，你知道的，如果你投掷
like a hundred darts that all hundred of them will end up in the square but some fraction of those darts will end up in the circle. And then based on that, you know the area of the circle, right, as like a fraction of the area of the square. And then you can actually approximate pi, like if you throw enough of these darts. So this is an idea where like you use a bunch of random numbers and you figure out, like in this case, pi, you figure
一百支飞镖，所有这 一百支都会落在正方形里，但其中一部分飞镖会落在圆里。然后基于此，你就知道了圆的面积，对吧，作为正方形面积的一个分数。接着，如果你投掷足够多的飞镖，你实际上就可以近似算出π。所以这个想法是，你使用一堆随机数，然后在这个例子中算出π的值，通过一种叫做蒙特卡洛抽样的东西来计算。你只需尝试一堆随机数，然后慢慢地、慢慢地，你寻找的数字就会越来越接近π，对吧？但你也可以将其用于概率分布。正如我刚才所说，如果你想在圆上挑选一个随机点，你也可以使用这种拒绝技巧，你基本上可以从圆中进行抽样。所以如果你在做计算机视觉之类的东西，这相当有用。
out the value of pi by like what's called Monte Carlo sampling. You just try a bunch of random numbers and slowly, slowly, the number you're looking for gets closer and closer to pi, right? But you can also use it for distributions. Like as I was saying, if you want to pick a random spot on the circle, you can also use it for distributions like as i was saying if you want to pick a random spot on the circle you can use this rejection technique and you can effectively like sample from the circle and so if you're doing like computer vision kind of stuff this is pretty useful um so this is cool for say like circles but if it gets really complex and in some high dimensional
所以这对于像圆这样的形状很酷，但如果变得非常复杂，处于某种高维空间中，你正在做一些机器学习，并且需要从某个非常高维度的复杂形状中进行抽样，那么这些拒绝抽样技术就会失效，因为你最终会拒绝掉所有东西，或者拒绝掉99.9999%的东西，结果什么也没做成。所以这是应对这种情况的一种方法，它被称为吉布斯抽样（Gibbs sampling）。
space you're doing some machine learning and you need to sample from some really complex shape in a really high dimension, then these rejection sampling techniques break down because you end up just rejecting everything or rejecting 99.9999 and just nothing gets done so this is one way to deal with that it's called gibbs sampling um and uh hopefully they do a much better job than i just did talking about this whole thing it's pretty complicated to cover but uh it starts you from the ground up and it starts by talking about just like basic statistics, like counting and things like that. And they work you through going from there to this Gibbs sampling, which is kind of like the de facto way to solve this problem. So I thought it was a really great read, and I thought for people who aren't familiar with this and are interested,
希望他们比我刚才讲得要好得多，因为要涵盖整个内容相当复杂。但它是从最基础的知识讲起，从基础统计学开始，比如计数之类的事情。他们带你一步步从那里走到吉布斯抽样，这可以说是解决这个问题的实际标准方法。所以我觉得这是一篇非常棒的读物，我认为对于那些不熟悉这一点但又感兴趣的人来说，他们绝对应该尝试一下。我得去看看——我粗略浏览了一下，但“门外汉”并不意味着无知，所以我需要一本《写给无知者的吉布斯抽样》。你们有《傻瓜书》系列。所以，我想这本可以算作本期节目推荐的工具，但我没有时间去尝试它。所以我姑且把它当作一则新闻吧。Hyperlapse是Instagram推出的一款新应用。
they should definitely give it a shot i'll have to i skimmed it but uninitiated doesn't mean ignorant so i need kids sampling for the ignorant you got the dummies for dummies so uh i guess this could have been the tool of the show, but I didn't have time to try it out. So I'll just make it a news item. Hyperlapse is a new app released from Instagram. And I saw something similar from Microsoft, and I don't understand the connection. I feel like it was also called Hyperlapse. But this Hyperlapse from Instagram allows you to record a video on your iPhone. I don't think it has Android yet, but iPhone.
我从微软那里也看到过类似的东西，我不明白这其中的联系。我感觉它好像也叫Hyperlapse。但Instagram这款Hyperlapse允许你在iPhone上录制视频。我觉得目前还没有Android版，只有iPhone版。
And like you walking down the street in New York City. And of course, like as you walk, you kind of the camera moves up and down. It's not stabilized. Right. And so then what they do is make a kind of a time lapse where they fast forward you through the video, but also kind of stabilize as you go. So you've probably seen these effects in various movies or commercials or whatever um or the other classic one is like you point at the clock in the center of grand central station uh there's some fancy clock and you point at that and you have all the people like whisking around you right um and so you could set up a tripod and do this or you know if you could stabilize the video you can just kind of hand
比如你走在纽约市的街道上。当然，当你走路时，相机的画面会上下晃动。它是不稳定的，对吧。然后他们所做的是制作一种延时视频（time lapse），通过快进带你快速浏览视频，同时在行进过程中进行某种程度的稳定。所以你可能在各种电影、广告或其他地方见过这种特效。或者另一个经典的例子是，你把镜头对准中央车站中心的那个大钟，那是一个很精美的大钟，你把镜头对准它，然后所有的人都像风一样从你身边呼啸而过，对吧。所以你可以架起一个三脚架来做这件事，或者如果你能稳定视频，你就可以直接
hold it for a while and you get these really interesting effects you know instagram's all about filters i guess well it's all about a lot of things but you know people on instagram like filters so this is using time as a filter and it seems pretty interesting so i'm definitely going to be checking it out but i think it just was announced or released like today 13 hours ago it says so this is like fresh off the presses is this the same as the uh like in google plus they have the auto awesome where if you take a bunch of pictures that look like they're a sequence it'll build a movie out of it is this the same thing or is it different so you but that doesn't try to like give a coherent viewpoint for
坚持一会儿，你就会得到非常有趣的效果，你知道Instagram的重点就是滤镜，我想，好吧，它的重点很多，但你知道Instagram上的人喜欢滤镜，所以这是把时间当作滤镜，这看起来挺有意思的，所以我绝对会去看看，不过我想它刚刚才宣布或发布，就像今天13小时前，上面是这么说的，所以这就像是刚刚出炉的头条新闻，这跟呃，就像Google Plus里的“自动精彩”是一样的吗，如果你拍了一堆看起来像是一个序列的照片，它就会把它制作成一部电影，这跟那个是一样的还是不同的？所以你但是那不会试图去给出一个连贯的视角，为了
instance right like it'll just stitch them together right this one actually tries it takes video and essentially tries to make a cool looking fast forward of the video that's stabilized so if you just fast forward normal video it's kind of like blurry but this stabilizes it so it actually like oh now i see what you're saying all right yeah you just watch the video yeah okay yeah i'll check it out it sounds cool so it definitely is it's cool it's just like a better fast forward, basically. Okay. Because you have certain videos that are cool,
比如，它只是把它们拼凑在一起，对吧？这个实际上会尝试，它获取视频，并基本上试图制作一个稳定、看起来很酷的视频快进效果，所以如果你只是快进普通视频，它会有点模糊，但这会让它稳定下来，所以它实际上就像，哦，现在我明白你的意思了，好吧，是的，你只要看视频就行了，好吧，是的，我会去看看，听起来很酷，所以它绝对是，它很酷，基本上就像是一个更好的快进。好的。因为有些视频很酷，
like you're on some beautiful drive through a cool town or on a train or an airplane or something, and you're flying over stuff, and it's cool. But if you have to watch it at real time, it's very boring. No one wants to watch it. So wait, what's wrong with watching in fast forward? It's blurry? Well, it's not that it's kind uh very boring no one wants to watch it so wait what's wrong with watching and fast forward it's blurry well it's not that it's yeah kind of blurry because you're you're bouncing around right like the train is vibrating a little and you know you're kind of like moving left and right so they're trying to pick a point and kind of keep the what the perceived viewpoint as if you were stabilizing the camera as if the camera is being held very stable at a certain point i see so they're like basically registering the frames together yeah and then like
比如你正开车穿过一个很酷的小镇，或者在火车上、飞机上之类的，你从上面飞过，这很酷。但如果你必须以实时速度观看它，那就非常无聊。没人想看。等等，快进观看有什么问题？是模糊吗？嗯，不是那种，有点呃，非常无聊，没人想看，所以等等，快进观看有什么问题？是模糊吗？嗯，不是那种，是的，有点模糊，因为你，你在上下颠簸，对吧？比如火车在轻微震动，你知道，你有点像在左右移动，所以他们试图选择一个点，并保持感知视角，就好像你在稳定相机，就好像相机在某个点被握得非常稳定一样。我明白了，所以他们基本上是将帧对齐在一起，是的，然后像
okay got it got it and there's some stuff about how they did it we can read about anyways yeah i need to jump on the instagram thing i totally missed that boat i missed every social every boat yeah we were just talking about this before the show where we are not socialites we're the anti-socialites when it comes to social networks okay book of the show my book of the show is denial why business leaders fail to look facts in the face and what to do about it um so this is pretty interesting um it actually it covers several different companies that have either completely failed or had to reinvent themselves. And it goes way back in time.
好吧，明白了，明白了，关于他们是如何做到这一点有一些内容，我们可以读一下。无论如何，是的，我需要赶上Instagram的潮流，我完全错过了那艘船，我错过了每一个社交的船。是的，我们在节目开始前刚刚讨论过这个，我们不是社交达人，当涉及到社交网络时，我们是反社交达人。好的，本期节目的书。我本期节目的书是《盲目：商业领袖为什么看不到事实，以及该怎么做》。嗯，所以这挺有意思的，它实际上涵盖了几家完全失败或者不得不重塑自我的不同公司。而且它的时间跨度很久远。
It actually covers Henry Ford and the Model T. So for people who don't know, someone told Henry Ford, hey, we should do the Model T in different colors because there are people who like't know um you know someone told henry ford hey we should do the model t in different colors because there are people who like you know the aesthetics uh you're changing the aesthetics and he said no and then other car companies started making cars that were you know red or or yellow or painted however you want and people loved it and he still said no and then people stopped buying his cars. And that's how that sad story ended.
它实际上涵盖了亨利·福特和T型车。所以对于不知道的人来说，有人告诉亨利·福特，嘿，我们应该生产不同颜色的T型车，因为有些人喜欢，不知道，嗯，你知道，有人告诉亨利·福特，嘿，我们应该生产不同颜色的T型车，因为有些人喜欢，你知道的美学，你在改变美学，而他说不，然后其他汽车公司开始生产红色的、黄色的或者随你涂成什么颜色的汽车，人们非常喜欢它，而他依然说不，然后人们就不再买他的车了。这就是那个悲伤故事的结局。
It was a really sad story, actually. Yeah, and a lot of these are actually quite sad. But there's a lot to take away from them. I haven't read the book yet, but it was recommended to me by a friend. And I'm definitely going to give it a read. But it covers tech industry it covers various ones there's actually
这实际上是一个非常悲伤的故事。是的，其中很多实际上都挺悲伤的。但有很多值得我们借鉴的地方。我还没读过这本书，但这是朋友向我推荐的。我绝对会读一读。但它涵盖了科技行业，涵盖了各种各样的事情，实际上
you know how they have the tamper proof seals on pretty much everything like water has a tamper proof seal now but that all started because someone someone who is just a sociopath was poisoning bottles of Tylenol.
你知道他们几乎在所有东西上都有防篡改密封，比如现在水有一个防篡改密封，但这全都是因为某个人，一个彻头彻尾的反社会者，在泰诺林药瓶里下毒。
They're actually taking capsules of, I think it was like cyanide, that were white, to look like Tylenol capsules, and putting them in Tylenol bottles and killing people. And of course, you know, people's natural reaction is to blame Tylenol and sue the Tylenol company. And, you know, after many months, they found out that it was this sociopath and they caught him and everything. But this is all about sort of how they dealt with that.
他们实际上拿了胶囊，我记得是白色的氰化物胶囊，看起来像泰诺林胶囊，把它们放进泰诺林瓶子里并杀死了人。当然，你知道，人们的自然反应是责怪泰诺林并起诉泰诺林公司。而且，你知道，几个月后，他们发现这是一个反社会者，并抓住了他以及所有这些。但这一切基本上都是关于他们如何处理这件事的。
Because, you know, from their perspective, they just saw people using Tylenol and dying, right? And anyways,, and anyways, all of these, each chapter is a different company with a, with a company, you know, breaking pandemic and,
因为，你知道，从他们的角度来看，他们只是看到人们使用泰诺林然后死去，对吧？无论如何，不管怎样，所有这些，每一章都是一家不同的公司，一家公司，你知道，面临大流行病，
and, and how they dealt with that or didn't. And so, you know, I just thought it was a, just a phenomenally interesting, interesting idea. And I'll definitely be reading it this week.
以及他们是如何处理的，或者没有处理。所以，你知道，我只是觉得这是一个非常有趣、非常有趣的想法，我本周绝对会读这本书。
Mine is not nearly, well, maybe it's more interesting less interesting doesn't seem as applicable as useful to your life as Jason's non-fiction book so previously I had recommended a book by Scott Lynch called The Lies of Locke Lamora and this is actually a series. And so the next two books, Red Seas Under Red Skies and The Republic of Thieves, I've read both of them now. And so I will recommend them as well, basically recommending now at least the first three books. I really liked the first book a lot. And the second and third book didn't disappoint, I guess. You know, when you read a first book sometimes like a whole new universe right so it's kind of hard to keep it up through many books right especially if they didn't think they would be writing a second book so i think this person did scott did and uh they
我的没那么，嗯，也许它更有趣，没那么有趣，看起来不像杰森的非小说类书籍那样对你的生活适用、有用。所以之前我推荐过一本斯科特·林奇的书，叫《洛克·拉莫拉的谎言》，这其实是一个系列。所以接下来的两本书，《血海红空》和《盗贼共和国》，这两本我都读过了。所以我也会推荐它们，基本上现在推荐至少前三本书。我非常喜欢第一本。第二本和第三本也没有让人失望，我想。你知道，当你读第一本时，有时就像一个全新的世界，所以要在一系列书中保持这种状态有点难，特别是如果他们没想到自己会写第二本的话，所以我觉得这个人，斯科特做到了，呃，他们
did a good job so it's not like world building as much like there's a lot of weird things in the world and they've not really revealed much more i guess but um you know the story advances the characters advance and uh i i kind of like the actually the second book i like the first book a lot and i think i like the second book a lot too the third book i'm kind of wishy-washy on uh i'm glad i read it because i wanted to find out what was happening to the people. But I didn't care for the style. The style is different, actually, in each of the three books. Like, instead of the same thing, like, you know, you read some books, like, I'm trying to think of a good example.
做得很好，所以它不完全是世界构建，因为世界里有很多奇怪的东西，他们也没有真正透露太多，我想，但是，你知道，故事在推进，角色在推进，呃，我其实挺喜欢第二本的，我很喜欢第一本，而且我想我也很喜欢第二本。第三本我有点犹豫不决，呃，我很高兴我读了它，因为我想弄清楚那些人身上发生了什么。但我不太喜欢它的风格。其实三本书的风格都不一样。就像，不是千篇一律，比如，你知道，你读一些书，比如，我在想一个好例子。
Some books, and, like, the same things happen to the characters every time. Like, the characters don't seem to be learning. And it's just, like, a good story, right? Because, like, it's like james bond like a james bond book right like james bond doesn't really much doesn't carry over he doesn't really get better or smarter through each book um and sometimes the books are about like the characters getting smarter and more powerful as the books go on and then in this one it seems almost as if they're just putting them in very different scenarios and almost a different style of
有些书，比如，每次主角身上都发生同样的事情。比如主角似乎没有在学习。这就像是一个好故事，对吧？因为，比如，这就像詹姆斯·邦德，就像一本詹姆斯·邦德的书，对吧？詹姆斯·邦德其实并没有改变太多，他并没有在每本书中变得更好或更聪明，嗯，有时书是关于角色随着书的发展而变得越来越聪明、越来越强大的，而在这一本中，感觉好像他们只是把角色放在非常不同的场景中，几乎每本书都采用不同的写作
writing for each of the books and i kind of enjoyed that oh cool yeah i'll check that out as if they're just putting them in very different scenarios and almost a different style of writing for each of the books and i kind of enjoyed that oh cool yeah i'll check that out time for tool of the show all right i'll try not to you know uh go into hyperbole here and i'll save a little bit of time my tool is actually rather simple it's next door um but you left it next door it's uh yeah so it's pretty cool basically you, you validate your address with them, and there's just a variety of different ways you can do that. And then it's effectively yet another social network that I probably won't participate in.
风格，我挺喜欢这一点的。哦，酷，是的，我会去看看。就好像他们只是把角色放在非常不同的场景中，几乎每本书都采用不同的写作风格，我挺喜欢这一点的。哦，酷，是的，我会去看看。节目工具时间！好的，我尽量不，你知道，呃，在这里使用夸张手法，我会节省一点时间。我的工具其实相当简单，是Nextdoor……但是你把它忘在隔壁了。它呃，是的，所以它挺酷的。基本上你，你用它验证你的地址，有各种各样不同的方法可以做到这一点。然后它实际上又是另一个社交网络，我可能不会参与其中。
But this one's kind of cool. If you're having a garage sale, and you want to know if your neighbors want to have a garage sale with you at the same time or something like that, you can basically think of it as a forum or a message board but it's um private to your neighborhood and uh there's a separate message board that's private to like the all the neighborhoods within five miles um but because you know you've validated your address you typically don't have to worry about spam and things like that. Oh, I heard about this.
但这个挺酷的。如果你要搞庭院旧货出售，并且想知道你的邻居是否想同时和你一起搞庭院旧货出售或类似的事情，你基本上可以把它看作是一个论坛或留言板，但它是对你的社区私密的，呃，还有一个单独的留言板，对比如五英里内的所有社区私密，但因为你知道，你已经验证了你的地址，你通常不必担心垃圾信息之类的事情。哦，我听说过这个。
Yeah, it seems pretty cool. They were saying actually like a ton of people, like a lot of neighborhoods have been registered already on this. Like it was kind of crazy like how much it's catching on, but no one seems to really be talking about it yet. Yeah, I mean, you know, I signed up. My neighborhood was definitely already on. There's a number of people from my neighborhood who are already on. You know, what I found is I was just browsing some of the content, and I just didn't see a lot of content.
是的，看起来挺酷的。他们实际上说有超级多的人，很多社区已经在上面注册了。这简直太疯狂了，它的流行程度有多高，但似乎没有人真正在谈论它。是的，我的意思是，你知道，我注册了。我的社区绝对已经在上面了。我社区里已经有好些人在上面了。你知道，我发现我只是浏览了一些内容，却没有看到很多内容。
I mean, there's maybe one message every three months, and most of the time it's just complaining. It's not really useful. So that was kind of sad, actually. But, you know, we'll have to see what develops. I mean, you know, this could, I see great potential. Yeah, it's just a matter of, you know, whether people realize that potential or not.
我的意思是，可能每三个月有一条消息，而且大部分时间只是在抱怨。这其实并不是很有用。所以这实际上有点遗憾，不过，你知道，我们得看看事态如何发展。我的意思是，你知道，这可能会，我看到了巨大的潜力。是的，这只是一个问题，你知道，人们是否意识到这种潜力。
Interesting. All right. Yeah. My tool of the show is Waze GPS navigation app, and as if we needed another. But this one has some features I like. So it also has some sort of social networking points earning thing uh that i don't use um and but the idea is that uh some
有趣。好的。是的。我本期节目的工具是Waze GPS导航应用，就好像我们还需要另一个一样。但这款应用有一些我喜欢的特色功能。所以它也有某种社交网络积分赚取的东西，呃，我不怎么用，但它的想法是，呃，有些
people do and it makes the network better because what it tries to do is use i feel like we had to have talked about this before but i looked it up and i haven't seen it uh it didn't come up that we had talked about this before um so if i did i apologize uh but if not this is awesome ways people enter like there's a policeman ahead or you know there's a traffic camera here or um you know traffic got there's a traffic accident you know on the right side of the road up ahead and people enter these things and so if you keep the app up while you're driving um you'll get alerts coming through and it'll ask you to even like validate like do you see an accident
人会用，这让网络变得更好，因为它试图做的是利用，我觉得我们以前肯定讨论过这个，但我查了一下，没看到，没有记录显示我们以前讨论过这个，所以如果我提过，我道歉；但如果没有，这太棒了。Waze上人们会输入，比如前面有警察，或者你知道这里有交通摄像头，或者，你知道，交通，前面路的右侧有交通事故，人们会输入这些东西，所以如果你在开车时开着这个应用，你就会收到警报，它甚至会要求你验证，比如你看到前面有事故了吗
up ahead right so they know when it clears and stuff and gives warnings but the thing for me it seems more like every gps app now says that they do kind of real-time traffic but this one seems to do a better job of it because they seem to be more quick about feeding back in like actual user reports and stuff and it'll even show you on the map like all the people driving around who have the app open um so living in the san francisco bay area there's like i forget like each morning it tells me there's like 2 000 people using it wow which is not a ton but like in a commute there's already like 2 000 people on the road um and if you kind of spread them out which is not a ton, but like in a commute, there's already like 2000 people on the road. Um, and if you kind of spread them out, this is not that big of an area. So that's a lot of
对吧？所以他们知道什么时候道路畅通并给出警告。但对现在的我来说，每个GPS应用似乎都说它们有某种实时交通功能，但这款应用在这方面做得更好，因为它们似乎能更快地反馈实际的用户报告之类的，它甚至会在地图上向你显示所有开着应用到处跑的人，所以住在旧金山湾区，有，我忘了，每天早上它告诉我大约有2000人在使用它，哇，虽然不是很多，但在通勤时，路上已经有大约2000人了，如果你把他们分散开，虽然不是很多，但在通勤时，路上已经有大约2000人了。而且如果你把他们分散开，这不是一个很大的区域。所以有大量的
data points that they get in real time. Um, yeah, that's great. And they're feeding it back in and it works really well. They're now actually owned by Google. So I guess they'll be integrating something with the Google stuff soon. Um, but I like this app and i use it every morning to check which i have several potential ways i can go to work and i always look on this and see which way i should go um but yeah like all gps apps there's slight problems where like if i leave now and in my commute's a little longer so by the time i am halfway through right it's like 20 30 minutes later so traffic has changed a lot oh yeah yeah all of a sudden there's an accident in front of you you can't really do anything but they know like every
他们实时获得的数据点。嗯，太棒了。他们把数据反馈回来，效果非常好。他们现在实际上被谷歌收购了。所以我想他们很快就会将某些东西与谷歌的东西整合在一起。嗯，我喜欢这个应用，我每天早上都用它来查看，因为我有几条潜在的上班路线，我总是看这个并决定应该走哪条路。但是，是的，就像所有的GPS应用一样，存在一些小问题，比如如果我现在出发，我的通勤时间会稍长一点，所以当我走到一半时，大概是20分钟30分钟以后，交通已经发生了很大变化。哦，是的，是的，突然你前面发生了一起事故，你真的无能为力，但他们知道，每天
day there's at least one accident so i feel like they should anyways yeah that's right they should just predict like like patrick what are you thinking come on you know that I'm going to give you an accident. So, yeah, anyways. All right. All right. Time for a discussion of Swift. So Swift is a new language that was introduced by Apple, I guess, a month or two ago. But it's been in development for a few years now. And basically, the point about Swift is to replace Objective-C. So Objective-C was popularized as being the only language that you could use to make iPhone apps. And it's also used to make OSX apps and things like that.
至少有一起事故，所以我觉得他们应该无论如何，是的，对，他们应该直接预测，就像，帕特里克，你在想什么？拜托，你知道我会给你制造一起事故的。所以，不管怎样。好了。好了。是时候讨论Swift了。所以Swift是苹果推出的一门新语言，我想，是一个或两个月前。但它已经开发几年了。基本上，Swift的重点是取代Objective-C。所以Objective-C作为制作iPhone应用的唯一语言而普及。它也被用来制作OSX应用以及诸如此类的东西。
And Objective-C has an open source compiler, so you could really use it to make anything in theory. And so Swift is meant to sort of come in and replace Objective-C and just kind of make developing for any of those devices a little bit easier. So it has a variety of features, many of which, you know, we've talked about on other episodes, but we'll cover them briefly. So it has a static typing with type inference. So if you listen to our Haskell episode, you know all about that.
而且Objective-C有一个开源编译器，所以理论上你可以用它来制作任何东西。因此，Swift旨在介入并取代Objective-C，让为所有这些设备进行开发变得稍微容易一些。所以它有各种各样的功能，其中许多功能，你知道的，我们在其他节目中讨论过，但我们会简要介绍一下。所以它具有带有类型推断的静态类型。如果你听过我们的Haskell那一期，你就对这个很熟悉了。
But basically, you know, it has the static typing. So, you know, you can't try to, you know, set an int equal to a string or anything like that. But most of the time, you don't have to put the type either, which is what makes a dynamic type language is popular, right? You can just say i equals 3, and it knows that i should be an integer but it has to be it has to be an integer from then on well that's right it has to every
但基本上，你知道，它有静态类型。所以，你知道，你不能试图，你知道，将一个整型（int）设为一个字符串或诸如此类的事情。但大多数时候，你也不必写出类型，这就是动态类型语言受欢迎的原因，对吧？你可以直接说i等于3，它就知道i应该是一个整数，但它必须是，从那时起它必须是一个整数。嗯，没错，它必须
reference of i needs to be an integer that's right that's right but you know i feel like that's true i feel like with dynamic languages you should be doing that anyways i mean that's like a personal yeah there's a pet peeve there seems to be there should be some reason there's probably some clever thing you can do where i can be equal to literally anything kind of the null pointer hack but also null pointers are dangerous or void pointers sorry not null pointers but void pointers right it's kind of the same thing a void pointer can be literally anything you want uh so but yeah it's just it's just drama yeah um so it also has generics which is huge i mean objective c still had like just array and then if you wanted like an object out of the array you have to say like you know get me the item at index one and then cast it to whatever and you
i的每一个引用都需要是一个整数，没错，没错，但你知道，我觉得这是真的，我觉得对于动态语言，你无论如何都应该这样做，我的意思是，这是一个个人的，是的，一个痛点，似乎应该有一些原因，可能有一些聪明的方法可以让你让i等于任何东西，有点像空指针（null pointer）黑客，但空指针也很危险，或者说void指针（void pointers），抱歉，不是空指针，是void指针，对吧，这有点像是一回事，一个void指针可以 literalmente 是你想要的任何东西；所以但是，是的，这只是，这只是戏剧性，嗯。所以它也有泛型，这太大了，我的意思是Objective-C仍然只有像数组这样的东西，然后如果你想要数组里的一个对象，你必须说，你知道，给我索引1的项目，然后把它强制转换成任何东西，而且你知道
know theoretically you could have an array where the first thing's a string the second thing's a number a third thing is something else and that's a terrible idea don't don't ever write code like that i mean if you really need like for example think about like say json in json you know uh an array could hold know, numbers and other arrays and maps in it, right? So like create a class that has those three things and make one of them non null, right? Like, like, don't try and rely on the compiler and the runtime, you know, casting to solve that problem for you, you know? So generic is like pair. So you say say like i want a pair but i want both things in the pair to be of the same type but i don't know which type they will be
理论上，你可能有一个数组，其中第一个是字符串，第二个是数字，第三个是别的什么，这是一个糟糕的主意，不要，千万不要写那样代码。我的意思是，如果你真的需要，比如，想想比如JSON，在JSON中，你知道，一个数组可以包含数字、其他数组和映射，对吧？所以，比如创建一个包含这三项的类，并使其中一项非空，对吧？就像，不要试图依靠编译器和运行时，你知道，通过强制转换来为你解决这个问题，你知道吗？所以泛型就像是pair（对）。所以你可以说，我想一个pair，但我希望pair中的两项是相同类型的，但我不知道它们会是什么类型
yeah exactly so so so with generics you know that's when you're writing the pair class but as someone who's using the pair class you could say like this is a pair of a int and a double or this is an array of strings. Versus Objective-C where everything was just a pair and array and you used casting to talk about what you meant. It has string templating, which is pretty awesome. It's something a lot of people
是的，完全正确，所以，所以在泛型中，那是你在编写pair类的时候，但作为一个使用pair类的人，你可以说这是一个由int和double组成的pair，或者这是一个字符串数组。相比之下，在Objective-C中，一切都只是pair和数组，你要用强制转换来表达你的意图。它有字符串模板（string templating），这相当棒。这是很多人
take advantage of. So you mean built-in support for this, or is this a library that they have? A built-in support, yeah. So for Java, for example, you have to use the string template third-party library to get this um but but in general this is pretty awesome i mean basically you know you you could imagine like um having a string and then saying like in embedded in the string could be say like percent name percent and then wherever you see
在利用的东西。所以你是说内置支持这个，还是他们有的一个库？是内置支持，是的。所以对于Java，例如，你必须使用第三方字符串模板库来获取这个，但总的来说，这相当棒，我的意思是，基本上，你知道，你可以想象，比如，拥有一个字符串，然后说，嵌入在字符串中的可以是，比如说，百分号name百分号，然后无论你在哪里看到
percent name percent it changes it to some variable so that's basically what templating is and it's a way to sort of write code that's you know very data driven so wait so the way this works is like if i have a string that says hello percent name i don't know is that the syntax hello the syntax it's actually it's like slash open parentheses and slash close parentheses but yeah so so if you have hello and then the special thing indicating name and name is currently set to jason and then i say print that string it'll say print hello jason and then if i say exactly the string is now equal to patrick and i print the string again well sorry the name is now equal equal to Patrick and I print the string again.
百分号name百分号，它就会把它变成某个变量，所以这基本上就是模板的作用，它是一种编写高度数据驱动的代码的方法。所以等等，它是这样工作的，如果我有一个字符串叫“hello percent name”，我不知道，那是语法吗？“hello”，语法其实是斜杠开头的括号和斜杠闭合的括号，但是的，所以如果你有“hello”，然后是表示名字的特殊符号，而名字当前被设置为“jason”，然后我说打印那个字符串，它就会打印“hello jason”，然后如果我说，精确地说，这个字符串现在等于“patrick”，我再次打印这个字符串，哦，抱歉。名字现在等于Patrick，我再次打印这个字符串，说“hello, Patrick”。完全正确。完全正确。好吧。是的，所以字符串模板非常有用。它有闭包（closures），并且有作为头等公民（first class citizens）的函数。
Oh, sorry. The name is now equal to Patrick and I print the string again and say, hello, Patrick. Exactly. Exactly. All right. Yeah. So string tumbling is very useful. It has closures and has functions as first class citizens.
所以我想我们在Haskell那一期中讨论过这些。所以你会注意到的第一件事是，Swift借鉴了很多函数式编程的东西。所以它实际上非常类似于即将推出的Java 8。所以你会注意到那里有许多相似之处。它还有运算符重载（operator overloading），这挺酷的，特别是如果你在做数学相关的事情。你知道，我不知道你有没有处理过这个，帕特里克，但像在这些，比如，你用过Java的矩阵库吗？我对运算符重载有复杂的看法。有时它很方便，但有时又很不方便，因为如果，你知道，
So I think we talked about these in the Haskell episode. So one thing you'll notice already is that Swift borrows a lot from functional programming. And so it's actually very similar to Java 8 when that comes out. So you'll notice a lot of similarities there. It also has operator overloading, which is pretty cool, especially if you're doing math stuff. You know, like, I don't know if you've had to deal with this, Patrick, but, like, in these, like, have you ever used, like, the Java matrix library? You know, I have mixed minds about operator overloading. Sometimes it's convenient, but sometimes it's not because if, you know,
就像，我们有，我不是一个高级代数专家，但，像，你知道，我对加号应该如何工作有一种直觉。所以如果你有一些东西并将运算符定义为加号，而这个加号的工作方式不是我所构思的那样，那就有点糟糕了，
like, we have, I'm not a high-level algebra person, but, like, you know, I kind of have like a feeling for how a plus should work. And so if you have something and define the operator as plus and the plus doesn't work kind of how I've conceptualized it to work, it's kind of bad
因为我往往会直接使用加号，而不会去查阅你写的关于加号如何工作的注释。相比之下，如果你写了一个我必须调用的函数，而我需要去查阅它的名字，我也很可能会阅读关于任何警告或，你知道的，
because I tend to just use the plus without going and looking up the comments you wrote about how plus works. Versus if you wrote a function that I had to call and I needed to go look up the name i'm probably also likely to read the comments about like any sort of warnings or you know the
它的确切用法的注释。所以对我来说，运算符重载有点吓人，因为我曾遇到过这样的情况：我使用了一个我以为应该以某种方式工作的运算符，但它却不那样工作。嗯，这说得通。我正试图脑海中想出一个好例子，但我，它从我脑海里溜走了。是的，嗯，好吧，其中一个我见过的例子是，当你有两个向量，然后你做乘法，是的，是的，这是一个好例子，你得到了点积（dot product），或者有时你得到一个向量，它是逐分量相乘（component wise multiplication），然后就像你真的不知道你会得到什么。我确实认为这是一个问题。我想，你知道，我，我不是说被坑过，但我曾对在Java中进行矩阵操作感到沮丧，你最终
exact usage of it um so for me operator overloading is kind of scary because i've had instances where i use an operator that i thought should work in a certain way and it just doesn't yeah that makes sense i'm trying to think of a good example off the top of my head but i i'm not it's escaping me right now yeah i mean well one of them the one i've seen is you know when you have two vectors and you do multiply yeah yeah that's a good example you get the dot product or sometimes you get a vector where it's like component wise multiplication yeah and it's like you kind of really know what you're gonna get um i do see that as a problem i think you know i've you know i've been like not burned but i've been frustrated with doing like matrix operations in java you end
会得到一团糟的代码，比如a点add括号b，点multiply，你知道我的意思，它看起来太丑陋了。是的，我认为Haskell有一种很好的方式来处理这个问题，比如你可以把任何函数写成中缀（infix），比如就像你说的，a点add开括号b，对吧，你就可以直接写a add b。哦，是的，对吧，所以你可以这样做，或者你可以说add a b，所以你可以这样做，所以你可以得到你所说的那种效果，我觉得这有点像，嗯，我，我的意思是，可能在像Swift或别的什么语言中没那么容易做到，但我认为这是Haskell的一个非常好的特性，你可以用那种方式做，这样你就可以实际写出那个东西，但如果你愿意的话，可以在中间使用它。
up with this mess where it's like a dot add parentheses b like dot multiply you know i mean it just kind of it looks so hideous yeah and i think haskell had a good way of dealing with that where like you can write any function as infix so like you're saying like a dot add open paren b right you can just write a add b oh yeah that's right so you can do it or you can say uh add a b yeah so you can do them yeah so you can get what you're talking about like i think that's kind of like well i i mean maybe it's not as easy to do in something like swift or whatever but i think that's actually a really nice uh feature ofkell that you can do it that way so that you can actually write out the thing but use it in the middle if you
是的，这说得通。是的，我觉得这两个都挺好的。我认为Haskell的想法可能，我同意，可能更好，因为你可以有一个相当具描述性的名字，比如像a malt，malt piecewise或类似的东西，
want. Yeah that makes sense. Yeah I think that like I think both of these are good. I think the Haskell idea is probably I agree it's probably better because you could have a name that's pretty descriptive like a like a malt malt piecewise or something
而不是使用乘法符号，但是，是的，无论如何，我觉得这两者都比Java 7的方式要好。我想Java 8无论如何都有运算符重载。所以这些基本上就是大功能，你会注意到，像Swift本身其实并没有做什么全新的东西，但它借鉴了许多不同语言的思想并将它们融合在一起，这挺酷的。它使用的是LLVM，
instead of using a multiplication sign but uh but yeah either way it's it's i think it's both of them are better than the java 7 way i think java 8 has operator overloading at any rate um so those are basically the big features you'll notice like swift um by itself it doesn't really do anything brand new but it takes a lot of ideas from different languages and kind of brings them together which is pretty cool it's using LLVM
所以我想我们过去讨论过LLVM，LLVM代表底层虚拟机（low level virtual machine）。所以例如，比如Java，假设Java，你编写Java代码，然后Java代码被编译成
so I think we've talked about LLVM in the past LLVM stands for low level virtual machine so for example like say Java, say, Java, you write Java code, and then the Java code gets compiled
所谓的Java字节码（bytecode），然后有一个JVM（Java虚拟机）来执行该字节码，对吧？所以，LLVM，还有另一个叫做CLI的工具，它是微软版本的LLVM，用于C Sharp、VB.NET以及那些东西。所以这两个家伙都把这个提升到了下一个水平。所以他们有一个LLVM解释器，就像Java有JVM一样。他们有LLVM。你可以把你的代码编译成字节码并运行它，就像你在Java中做的一样。但你也可以从LLVM字节码转换成机器码。
to what's called Java bytecode, and then there's a JVM, which executes that bytecode, right? So, LLVM, and also another one called CLI, which is Microsoft's kind of version of LLVM, and it's for C Sharp and VS, VB.NET and those things. So both of these guys kind of take it to the next level. So they have an LLVM interpreter, just like Java has the JVM. They have the LLVM. And you can compile your code to bytecode and run it, just like you can in Java. But you can also go from LLVM bytecode to machine code.
这就是Java没有的东西。现在，你知道，如果你转向机器码，就没有回头路了，对吧？我的意思是，现在你构建的东西只能在，比如说，iPhone或类似设备上运行。但那个额外的步骤允许你进行许多很酷的优化，同时，在你需要的时候还能拥有虚拟机（VM）带来的优势。它对于优化也有优势，如果你是一个有兴趣将LLVM字节码转换为机器码，并想出聪明的方法来识别LLVM字节码中的操作模式，并为诸如奔腾（Pentium）、奔腾三代生成最佳机器码的人，我不知道。现在没人用那些了，但奔腾三代由于某种原因有这个你非常喜欢的指令，你找到了生成该字节码的方法。那么任何在前端拥有任何编译为LLVM字节码的语言的人都可以利用针对奔腾三代的这种优化。所以无论是来自Swift、Objective-C还是常规C，如果它处于LLVM字节码这种中间格式，你其实并不关心它来自哪里，因为你可以在那里识别模式并生成最佳机器码。
So that's the thing that Java does not have. Now, you know, if you go to machine code, there's no going back, right? I mean, like now you've built something that only works on, you know, an iPhone or something like that. But that extra step allows you to do sort of a lot of cool optimizations, while at the same time, having the advantage of the the vm when you need it for it also has the advantage for optimization you can do work on if you're a person interested in taking something from the llvm bytecode to the machine code and coming up with clever ways of recognizing patterns of operations and the llvm bytecode, and producing machine code that's optimal
没错。所以Objective-C和Swift都会转换成这种LLVM字节码。然后从那里开始，它们的待遇完全一样。因此，为Objective-C从LLVM转换到机器码所做的大量工作，不需要在Swift身上重复一遍。为标准欢呼！是的，没错。嗯，这难道不奇怪吗？这有点像通过示例建立的标准，你知道吗？
for whatever, like Pentium, Pentium threes. I don't know. Nobody uses those anymore, but Pentium threes like that, that just for some reason has this one instruction that you love and you figure out a way to generate bytecode to that. Then anyone who has any language in the front end compiles into LLVM bytecode can take advantage of that optimization for Pentium 3s. So whether it's coming from Swift or Objective-C or regular C, if it's in that intermediate format of LLVM bytecode, you kind of don't care where it came from because you can recognize patterns there and produce the optimal machine code.
它不是真正的标准，但它就像是一个参考实现。嗯，我的意思是，替代方案，这开始变得有点超出我所了解的范围了，但替代方案，如果你看看GCC项目，他们也使用某种，他们不叫字节码，但他们有一种中间语言。所以他们的前端被编译成这种中间语言，但他们基本上只打算让它用于他们自己的项目。所以它有各种各样的细微差别和复杂性，
That's right. So both Objective-C and Swift go to this LLVM bytecode. And then from there, they're both treated the same way. So all the work that's gone into going from LLVM to machine code for Objective-C doesn't have to be duplicated for Swift. Yay for standards. Yeah, that's right. Well, isn't that weird? It's kind of like a standard by example, you know?
而且很难处理，但它非常非常优化，很多时候你能从GCC中获得非常好的代码，对吧？但这套LLVM从底层开始就一直打算以这种方式被许多不同的前端所使用，并用于针对不同的后端生成最优代码，所以他们在设计时就考虑到了这一点，因此他们做出了一些易于使用的选择。是的，完全正确，是的，它并不是真正的标准，我不认为有一个标准机构来制定它，但他们做出了它，然后说，嘿，其他人可能也会想用这个。是的，绝对的，是的，我觉得这很有趣，就像，是的，它就像是通过作为参考而成为标准。我猜，就像你说的，你有一个很好的说法，通过示例建立的标准。
It's not really a standard, but it's like, it's a reference implementation. Well, so I mean, the alternative, and this starts to get a little outside of where I have a lot of knowledge about, but the alternative, if you take kind of the GCC project, they also use kind of, they don't call it bytecode, but they have an intermediate language. So their front end is compiled to this intermediate language, but they kind of only ever meant for it to be used by their project. And so it has all sorts of nuances and complexities,
它并不是真正的标准。他们只是把它开源了。而且因为他们做得很好，它已经成为了事实上的标准。就是这样。是的，是的，这说得通。所以，是的，它显然是针对移动端进行优化的。正如你所料，它与Objective-C有非常好的集成，因为它们最终
and it's very difficult to work with but it's very very optimized like you get really good code out of gcc a lot of times right but this llvm was kind of from the ground up always intended to be used in this way by many many different front ends and for producing optimal against different back ends so they kind of designed it that way so they made certain choices that kept it easy to use yeah exactly yeah it's not really a standards like i don't think there's a standards body that does it but like they made it and said hey this would probably other people might want to use this as well yeah yeah definitely yeah i think it's interesting like uh yeah it's sort of like a standard just by being a reference. I guess, like you said, you had a good way of saying it, standards by example.
都被编译成相同的东西。基本上，你用过Swig吗，帕特里克？不，我选“没有”。我想我用过，但就当没用过吧。所以，是的，Swig这个东西有点像，就像Java源代码，当你调用其中一个Java函数时，
It's not really standards. They just made it open source. And because they did a good job, it's become a de facto standard. There we go. Yeah, yeah, that makes sense. So, yeah, it's optimized for mobile, clearly. It has very good integration with Objective C as you might expect because they're both
它知道去调用C++函数。这个的工作原理有点类似。所以有一个叫“桥接头文件（bridging header）”的概念，你只需要在项目中告诉Xcode你需要从Swift访问哪些Objective-C文件，反之亦然。然后，对于其中每个文件，它都会在底层生成一堆包装代码。这挺酷的。这是那种“开箱即用”的东西。
compiled down to the same thing so basically have you ever used Swig Patrick? no I'm going to go with no I think I have but just go with no so yeah Swig is this thing that kind of,, like Java source code, where when you call one of the Java functions,
所以Objective-C中的函数，你可以直接从Swift中调用它们，反之亦然。我希望它比把C++代码包装进Java或者从Java调用C++更好用，我们做过这个，我以前做过，但，是的，它总是有点乱，而且从来没有完全像你想要的那样工作，嗯，是的，我觉得，你知道，C++到Java的问题在于它们有不同的VM。嗯，这一直是个问题。嗯，可以说是不同的二进制文件，稍微挥挥手这样说。所以C++需要以一种方式编译，Java以另一种方式编译。
it knows to go and call the C++ function. This works kind of similar. So there's an idea called a bridging header, and you just tell Xcode in the project what Objective-C files you need to access from Swift and vice versa. And then it, for each of those files, generates a bunch of wrapper code under the hood. It's pretty cool. It's one of these things that just kind of works.
但接着Java需要知道如何调用编译后的C++，以及如何解释返回的结果。因为它们使用不同的标准。C++不是虚拟机，而Java是JVM，所以那里没有真正的主会合点。我猜，如果你用Clang构建C++代码，并且如果Clang有一个Java编译器，我不知道这是真是假，或者更确切地说，如果LLVM有一个Java编译器，也许你可以做更复杂的事情，因为那样的话，这两门语言就会在LLVM级别相遇，所以就像我知道Python可以调用
So the functions in Objective functions objective c you can just call them from swift and vice versa i hope it works better than this extra step swinging c++ code into java or calling into c++ from java which we do i've done before but yeah it was always kind of messy and it never works quite like you want it to um yeah i think the uh you know the issue with the c++ to java is they have different VMs. Well, that was always a problem. Well, kind of different binaries is one way of kind of saying it to hand wave a little. So you have the C++ needs to be compiled in one way, the Java in another.
C++代码，那要干净得多，嗯，是的，有一个Boost Python，我见过那个。嗯，还有其他方法，嗯，但它们是为之内置的，嗯，有一些方法可以像，C++优化真的非常快，所以你只想用Python脚本来调用这个，而且它的运行相当干净，但话又说回来，是的，所以它可以做得好或坏，但你是说Swift和Objective-C结合得相当好。这个做得非常好。我拿了一个Objective-C库并把它加到一些Swift代码中，
But then the Java needs to know how to call into the compiled C++ and then how to interpret kind of the results that come back. Because they use a different standard for it. C++ is not a VM, and Java is the JVM, and so there's not really like a meeting point there. I would imagine that if you built C++ code with Clang, and if Clang had a Java compiler, I don't know if that's true or not or rather if llvm had a java compiler then maybe you could do something more sophisticated because then like those two languages are meeting at the llvm level so like i know there's a python can call
它直接就能用了。我其实相当惊讶。但我认为它之所以运行得这么好，是因为有这个LLVM中间层。这对于一门新语言来说很重要，因为最初不会有很多Swift库，对吧？能够使用Objective-C库是一件好事。是的，我的意思是，你基本上
into c++ code it's much cleaner um yeah there's a boost python i've seen that yeah well and other ways yeah but they kind of built it in for it yeah there's like ways python i've seen that yeah well and otherwise yeah but they kind of built it in for it yeah there's like ways to do like the c++ optimization is just really fast and so you just want to have a python scripting of calling this uh and it works pretty cleanly but there again like that yeah so it can be done good or bad but you're saying that swift objective c is done pretty well. This one was done really well. I took an Objective-C library and added it to some Swift code,
白白得到了所有的Objective-C库，这挺酷的。酷。所以，是的，有一个关于Swift的博客。Reddit上有一个关于Swift的版块。去看看吧。
and it just worked. I was actually rather surprised. But I think the reason why it works so well is because of this LLVM middle layer. And that's important for a new language because initially there won't be a lot of Swift libraries, right? It will be good that you can use the Objective-C libraries. Yeah, I mean you basically get all
它挺酷的。你可以成为第一批人。现在加入还为时不晚。没错。没错。我的意思是，如果你哪怕只是做了一件你可能认为是平凡的事情，比如，我不知道，一个日历应用，或者一些帮助你与Facebook对话的库之类的。我不知道。而且你使用了Swift，它实际上最终可能会变得非常、非常、非常受欢迎，
of the Objective-C libraries you kind of just get for free, which is pretty cool. Cool. So yeah, there's a blog about Swift. There's a Reddit, subreddit on Swift. And check it out.
因为外面没有太多这样的东西。或者你可能会陷入某种情况，它可能会砸锅，对吧？我们不知道。不过你喜欢它，所以杰森听起来对它竖起了大拇指。是的，我觉得它相当扎实。有一件事他们还在观望，我不太疯狂，事实上这不是一个明显的决定，但他们仍在弄清楚对编译器该怎么做，是开源它还是不开源。如果你读了
It's pretty cool. And you can be one of the first. It's still time to get on the ground floor. That's right. That's right. I mean, if you make even something which you might think is mundane, like, I don't know, a calendar app or some library to help you talk to Facebook or something. I don't know. And you use Swift, it could actually end up being really, really, really popular
开发者的博客，他们的博客里字面写着：“我们还不知道是否要将其开源。”这总是让我感到不安，因为，你知道，如果你不开源它，它真的无法获得吸引力。嗯，它或许可以，但这很大程度上取决于，在这种情况下，苹果，对吧？就像，如果苹果出于内部原因决定取消它，它可能是一个好东西，比如社区可能想要它，对吧？但是，苹果决定不这么做。他们可以在那个时候将其开源，但你知道，尽早开源并拥有
because there's not many out there. Or you could fall into some sort of, it could bomb, right? We don't know. You like it, though, so Jason sounds like he gives it a thumbs up. Yeah, I think it's pretty solid. One thing they're on the fence about i'm not crazy about um the fact that this isn't like an obvious decision but they're still trying to figure out what to do with the compiler like whether to open source it or not like if you read blogs from
因为市面上没多少这种产品。或者你可能会遇到某种情况，它可能会彻底失败，对吧？我们不清楚。不过你挺喜欢它，所以贾森听起来像是给它点了个赞。对，我觉得它挺扎实的。有一件事他们还在犹豫不决，我不太喜欢，那就是这并不是一个显而易见的决定，但他们仍在琢磨如何处理编译器，比如是否将其开源。如果你读过博客的话
the developers they're they're the blog literally say we don't know whether we're going to open source it yet and uh that always makes me uneasy because, you know, if you don't open source it, it really can't gain traction. Well, it could, but it's very dependent on, in this case, Apple, right? Like, if Apple decides for internal reasons to cancel it, it may have been a good, like, community may have wanted it, right? But, like, Apple decides not to do it. They could open source it at that point but you know it's always better to kind of open source it early and have
来自开发者的博客，字里行间都在说我们还不知道是否要将其开源，呃，这总是让我感到不安，因为，你知道的，如果你不开源它，它就真的很难获得关注。嗯，也有可能，但这在很大程度上取决于，就本例而言，就是苹果公司，对吧？比如，如果苹果出于内部原因决定取消它，它可能本来是个好东西，比如社区可能很想要它，对吧？但结果却是苹果决定不做。他们当然可以在那个时候再开源，但你知道，尽早开源并让
input and everybody on board from the start like what a disaster c-sharp was like c-sharp is actually still surprisingly popular but like a lot of people they had c-sharp they had mono which was like the open source that's basically reverse engineer all of c sharp and then for a long time mono didn't work 100 the way c sharp did like the microsoft compiler did and so just the whole thing is kind of a nightmare and by the time it stabilized i completely lost interest um but you know let's hope that that doesn't happen here. All right. Well, thanks for all the letters, letters, emails and postings. We see them occasionally, although we just talked about how antisocial we are.
一开始并没有得到所有人的支持，比如C#简直是一场灾难，虽然C#现在实际上仍然出奇地受欢迎，但当时很多人面临的情况是，他们有C#，还有Mono——也就是基本上逆向工程了整个C#的开源实现。在很长一段时间里，Mono的工作方式并不能100%像C#那样，或者说不像微软的编译器那样，所以整个事情简直是一场噩梦。等到它稳定下来的时候，我已经完全失去兴趣了，嗯……但你知道，希望这里不会发生那种情况。好吧。总之，谢谢大家发来的信件、邮件和留言。我们偶尔会看到，尽管我们刚刚才聊过我们有多么不合群。
But we do see postings on Google Plus and Facebook and Twitter and the emails. And we do appreciate their community involvement. Yeah, definitely. Definitely. and we do appreciate their community involvement. Yeah, definitely, definitely. We definitely, you know, we've been making a habit of talking about an email or a Google Plus or Facebook post in the beginning of the show, and that's because we've been getting so much good content from you guys and so many good questions. Although we'll probably offend a bunch of people because we don't talk about theirs.
但我们的确会看到Google Plus、Facebook、Twitter以及电子邮件上的留言。我们确实很感激大家的社区参与。是的，绝对的。绝对的。我们确实，你知道的，我们已经习惯在节目开始时讨论一封电子邮件、一个Google Plus或Facebook的帖子，那是因为我们从你们那里收到了太多优质的内容和这么多好问题。尽管我们可能还是会得罪不少人，因为我们没有聊到他们的内容。
If we offended you, send us another email. You can even get all the money you paid for this back yeah that's right oh man but i can't give you back the hour of your life no that part you can't get back so uh but you can't give us back the bandwidth either so it's we're even okay this is devon all right till next time. All right, guys. Catch you later. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你被我们得罪了，请再给我们发封邮件。你甚至可以把为此支付的所有钱都要回去，是的，没错，天哪，但我可没办法把你们生命中的这一个小时还给你们。不，那部分你是拿不回来的。所以，呃，但你也没办法把带宽还给我们，所以我们扯平了。好了，我是Devon。好吧，下次见。好了，伙计们，回头见。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。片头曲是Binar Pilot的《Axo》。《Programming Throwdown》采用知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0协议发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，可以混音、改编作品，但你必须署名我和Patrick，并采用相同的协议进行共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。